braderie dans les 26 enseignes du verre
d'une megastore de france le magasin de
montigny le bretonneux n'échappe pas à
la règle de -50 à -70% hier depuis hier
sur la quasi intégralité des rayons et
ce afin de faire rentrer des fonds
virgin megastore est en redressement
judiciaire depuis le 14 janvier la
société rougier et play a certes fait
une offre de reprise mais ne
souhaiterait garder avec quelques 285
salariés et sept à huit magasins celui
de montigny n'en ferait pas partie en
raison de discussions difficiles
visiblement selon les syndicats avec le
propriétaire des locaux
le groupe hammerson d'autres repreneurs
peuvent encore se manifester d'ici au 23
mai 23 mai pardon et le tribunal de
commerce doit ensuite se prononcer ce
sera début juin le plan social qui
semble inévitable qu'en pensent les
clients nous en avons rencontré
quelques-uns cet après midi je me suis
fait trop virgin va donc en gros
quelques jeux vidéo et puis de trois
séries animées de congés ça ce matin
d'un côté j'étais content parce qu'avec
les -70 voilà je parle en profiter mais
d'un autre côté je me suis dit que si
verte une ferme s'arrête assez embêtant
si je crois que l'appareil avait plus
grand chose déjà rare quand même un
seuil avait déjà pas mal de ce truc
était parti du surtout dans l'oeuf du
côté des films séries mais mais voilà
j'ai trouvé mon bonheur
les fournitures pour la future rentrée
scolaire stylos cahiers que c'était
acquis un peu de petits gadgets
mon seul problème c'est que tout ce qui
était intéressant ces partis hier voilà
écrit là bon courage pour ce
malheureusement qui vont se retrouver au
chômage
à noter que l'enseignant annonce la fin
de ces soldes pour le 25 mai mais les
rayons sont déjà quasiment vides les
salariés pourraient être dispensés
d'activité d'ici la fin de la semaine